welcome everybody to this spectator tv
special on building opportunities
regenerating britain's left behind
communities my name is andrew neil i'm
chairman of the spectator and delighted
to welcome you and to begin with a
special thanks to bae systems uh which
have made this event possible uh we've
done several events in the past with bea
they've been a wonderful partner for us
and for this particular subject i can't
imagine a better partner
is one of our country's greatest
industries businesses manufacturing
companies research companies based all
over the united kingdom so they know all
about
various communities and not just inside
the circle line in london and we'll be
hearing later from roger carr the
chairman of bae systems on what it all
means for them what we want to look at
over the next hour and a bit more than
an hour is um
the government's what it now calls the
leveling up policy the idea of trying to
level up the poorer regions of the
united kingdom to make them closer in
prosperity and dynamism to the richer
regions which are largely in london and
the south east it's not a new problem uh
britain has uh lived with this uh
problem for many many years regional
policy goes way back to the 1930s and
the great depression after the second
world war every government had his own
version of regional policy we're not
quite sure exactly how much of a
difference they really made in the end
and one of the things we'll look at is
whether leveling up is actually just a
new name for regional policy and this
time where can it succeed where others
in the past have not necessarily failed
but kind of disappointed
what can we do this time what have we
learned what will happen this time so to
kick it off i'm delighted to say that we
have someone who's right at the heart of
this andy haldane
has been key figure in the bank of
england he now played a pivotal role in
writing the government's leveling up
white paper which contains the growth
strategy for what it hopes to achieve
and he is with us now and i'm going to
pass straight over to andy he's going to
make some remarks and then he and i will
have a quick discussion after that i
will go over to roger carr but andy over
to you first
well andrew thank you for that kind of
introduction and morning everyone um
really pleased to be at this
spectator event and really pleased that
it's sponsored by bae systems and by
roger who will hear from
as
andrew hinted be systems uh are a great
example
of just the sort of anchor institution
local leader that we need to make good
on leveling up and i look forward to
hearing from roger about the role they
are playing
let me in my brief intro remarks andrew
just touched upon leveling up in general
terms and how it might unlock more of
that potential that you mentioned
with my jumping off point
being
that white paper that you mentioned
published a few months ago
i assume
everyone has done their pre-reading and
has fully digested those 325
pages
off the back of that you know
many outside commentators have raised
some good
and legitimate questions
not so much about the desirability
but more about the deliverability
uh of that program so i thought why i
might focus my initial comments was on
just that
or put differently to get my retaliation
in first uh andrew
and i think the biggest challenge it
faces and the obvious one i think is
yeah will it be stuck with
uh is the political will is the money
there
to deliver especially giving given the
other pressures
uh both time and money facing government
right now not least
the ukraine crisis and the cost of
living
crisis and a casual glance to the
history books
as andrew uh uh hinted
does suggest a degree of skepticism uh
is understandable here the uk has not
lacked the regional policies that have
come thick and fast for at least 100
years roughly rotating on a decadal
cycle and of course therein
lies
the answer like therein lies the key to
failure
which is if you have
regional disparities as
deeply entrenched as the uk
any absence of longevity
in those regional policies
uh pre-commits you to failure and fairly
is what we have had hitherto
so what is different than in the white
paper why might
this be the point where history chooses
not to repeat itself well let me mention
a few of the factors relevant there
one of them
is i think just at the moment we do have
fortuitously an alignment of the stars
uh economically socially and
politically all three so on the
economics of this
it just happens that if you were to
unlock that potential in the country
through leveling up i reckon you could
boost incomes and outputs
by at least between 50 and 100 billion
pounds
each year forever hereafter which is a
decent chunk of change and certainly
well worth having
uh given how tight budgets are
right now
and what's true economically is no less
true from a sort of social justice
perspective those spatial disparities in
the uk
are the largest in the western world are
their largest levels
since at least late victorian
times and i'm blocking those barriers to
opportunity
among the poorest people and poorest
places has i think a huge amount
societally going for it and finally on
the politics of this others are much
more expert than me
but suffice to say
it seems like the me that the red wall
will continue to be
a battleground politically for as far
as the eye
can see to what extent
will the cost of living crisis reshape
that economically socially politically
well it will tighten budgets
for sure
but given that the burden of the cost of
living crisis will i think fall
disproportionately
on those poorer people
on those poorer places
i see no slackening of resolve
economically socially politically as a
result of that if anything you might
even find
the opposite
being true so if the the keystone of
leveling up success is longevity
and if longevity means in turn both
cross-party
and indeed cross-generational support
i think the current alignment of the
stars
economically socially politically
suggests that support will remain in
place for some little while
to come
second i hear you ask possibly
what about the money who's to pay for
all this
delivery then with budgets being tight
and tightening
well that is true those constraints are
real
but let me mention three factors that
weigh in the opposite direction each
relevant i think to this leveling up
agenda
and the first of those
is as i've just said leveling up is a
long-term commitment it's underpinned by
12 missions that stretch out to 2030
which means
it encompasses a whole range of spending
rounds be multiple
bytes at the spending
cherry
and that means today's fiscal envelope
is not will not define the success or
failure
of
leveling up
second
i find among the external commentariat
there's always an over focus on new
money where's the new money uh in
the white paper and in fact
even a small
re-tilting of existing budgets
is often much more effective as a means
of enabling
leveling up so let me give an example as
little as one percent of a re-tilt
in existing budgets
towards poorer parts of the uk
would deliver a fiscal transfer about
twice the size
of the government's
flagship leveling up fund new money if
you like so when it comes to leveling up
old money often matters as much or more
uh than new money and that is indeed
what's happening it's in the leveling up
white paper
uh it was signaled very clearly that
there would
be a re-tilting of existing budgets
towards poorer places
on r d
on culture spend
on
uh housing spend on
transport spend
and the final point i'd make and in some
ways i think the most important of all
is that
public money
or success in leveling up is not
exclusively or perhaps even mainly
about public money it's as importantly
about the crowding in of private monies
and private
uh investment and the good news here
is despite the public purse being shut
that pool
of private
patient capital
is deep and liquid and is looking for
worthwhile homes at high returns
and those returns really are available
across all four corners of the uk we
know that because the likes of legal in
general have been putting their balance
sheet to work and harvesting those
returns
now for more
uh than
a decade
finally um just on delivery
um what should give us any greater
confidence the white paper will make
good
uh where past
regional policies
have
failed well i think here
uh the white paper genuinely did seek to
break
new ground uh andrew in fact i can
summarize
those 325 pages for you need not read
them actually in one sentence
the white paper defined a new model of
government
and a new model of governance
so let me un-pick that quickly buy a new
model of government
what i mean is that the white paper
signaled
i think a pretty significant
rewiring
of the whitehall
machine a rewiring that means that
government policy decisions
in future
will be viewed explicitly
through a spatial lens the question will
be asked
are those policies
helping to shrink those spatial gaps and
that has not been the case in the past
some departments have been operating
effectively place blind and indeed some
transport culture r d housing it can be
operating in a way that's actually been
amplifying those regional differences
rather than shrinking them that
is
now changing and changing decisively
but second i think in some ways even
more importantly
the new model not of government
but of governance because
the route to success in leveling up if
you look at our history if you look at
international history case studies is
that it doesn't lie
in central government action
uh exclusively or perhaps even mainly
rather it lies in local leadership
and local agencies by which i mean not
just local government
that is to say the deepening and
widening of the devolution agenda that
was signed posted in the white paper but
i also though mean
the leadership of businesses like ba
systems and roger of universities and
colleges of community groups and civil
society and its many in various forms
that is to say the heavy lifting of
leveling up
comes from
those anchor
civic institutions
creating clusters
growing those clusters into genuine uh
superclusters creating both economic
and social activity
and infrastructure across the uk
andrew there are already 20 or 30 of
those clusters we need them across the
four corners of the uk and the ask of
government
from those clusters
is not buckets load more money
it is instead to be empowering
and enabling
of those actors across sectors uh and
over time that's the new model of
governance it's not what we've had in
the uk previously but one i hope the
leveling up white paper didn't just
signpost but can now
make good on andrew let me stop there
and
pass back to you
andy thank you very much for that that's
fascinating fascinating let me drill
down on a couple of things uh there and
start with this with a broad question
it's not it's not all going to be done
in just a decade but if we if we put
2030 as the first horizon the first
gave us eight years to try to make a
difference
what would what would success look like
by 2030 not that all the disparities
have gone and all the rest of it but the
progress had been made what would how
would we measure that progress
yeah
i think um
at the highest level uh andrew the way
you would see that progress showing up i
think this is realistic on an eight-year
horizon
is that what we've seen um over the last
at least half century
uh is
you know we've seen in the most
successful cities
them serving as a magnetic attractor
uh of business
of finance
of people
of culture
and the so-called left behind places
serving uh as the opposite end of the
magnet and repelling uh each of
those factors ultimately what we need to
success would look like
the left behind places starting to
attract
rather than repel
all those things we know are the raw
ingredients
of success it's about turning those
uh vicious cycles
into virtuous ones in many more places
across the uk now i wouldn't
underestimate that task that is
essentially
a turning of the tide that's been
flowing for at least 70 years
uh in the uk those gaps will not be
closed but i think success
would look like them no longer
widening and perhaps even
starting to undo some of the widening
we've seen that's true across living
standards it's true across
infrastructure it's true health outcomes
it's true across education and skills so
all of those dimensions are ones where a
turning of the tide
is i think both realistic
and a diagnostic on success for leveling
up
britain is not the only country of
course with regional disparities
italy has an enormous social disparity
actually
depending on which way you measure it
you could argue that
the
the the disparity between the south of
italy and the north is actually wider
than between the south of england and
the north of england uh germany has
poured billions upon billions into east
germany
but east germany is still uh
considerably poorer than uh western
germany france has its own
regional disparities they're probably
not as big uh as the united kingdom is
there anywhere when you were working on
on this andy that
there were places you could look at
abroad get some international
comparisons and think hey that's a good
idea they've done that well let's let's
bring that to the uk
uh we actually did you know both in the
work for the the white paper indeed some
of the work i'd done previously
um did look in quite some detail at
places that have made a successive
leveling up and asked the question
you know what was the secret source
uh in
those places i mean truth be told you
have to be careful in doing that of
course
because there are as many or more
examples of failure as there are
of success and that is you know a
sobering conclusion uh for us all but
you you mentioned the german example and
certainly the german example is one in
which not just uh with the introduction
of east germany but even prior to that
where differences
between different parts of germany and
france
were materially smaller
and differences between them have been
shrinking rather than widening over a
number
of
decades you look for example to places
in the states
you know not so much uh individual
states but cities within those states
that have somehow turned
uh the post uh industrial uh
detroit being a case
uh in point so i think there is
lessons and inspiration to be drawn
from elsewhere i mean the uk is an
outlier internationally
along most uh dimensions and i think as
importantly andrew
the differences within region and indeed
often the differences within
cities
are larger than those between regions
so it is the case you know that um
the largest proportion of people living
in poverty are living here in london in
poverty
uh those distinctions are
uh often sharpest within
on the face of it our most successful
city so leveling up is not a city versus
town it's not a north versus south thing
it is hyper
local those hyper local differences
again are more acute here than elsewhere
i mean the picture is not
without successes i mean if you if you
look at
some of our
major you could call them a major these
are cities that came to prominence in
victorian times with the industrial
revolution
if you look at them now compared to 30
40 years ago there's been an incredible
transformation you just need to go to
manchester to see that or liverpool or
leeds or newcastle or birmingham
yeah but
that's had a price let's take manchester
which in some ways is the most
successful uh city
in the united kingdom outside of london
it really seems to have a
kind of sense that is driving forward uh
for all sorts of reasons but there's
been a price to pay
which is the success of manchester has
meant that the cities all around it not
the cities the towns perhaps the small
what you might call the provincial towns
uh all around it
they've not been dragged up by that
indeed i've seen some people argue that
they've actually paid the price because
manchester has created this cluster
which everybody wants to be there rather
than 10 or 15 miles away i mean that is
that is a problem isn't it
it is i mean a couple of points on on
your question andrew if i may even for
those places you name checked as having
been successful cities which on most
dimensions they are the birminghams the
bristols the manchester's the leedses
the newcastles uh the edinburgh glasgow
the belfasts the cardiffs the bristols
even
in each and every one of those cases
what you find is a load doing well in an
absolute sense
those cities are doing less well
than their international comparators of
a similar sort of size so even for our
successful second cities
they're currently flying below potential
there is potential to be unwrapped there
to catch up uh with our international
counterparts but the other problem you
mention is that you know for every
leads you have at bradford
for every newcastle you have a
sunderland
and that is true that's true of not just
of
uh satellite towns but of some satellite
cities as well in the two cases
that uh i uh i gave there
i think this is where
uh we need to think and i'll use this
language in my opening remarks would you
think beyond the notion of city clusters
towards genuine superclusters that
encompass
uh neighboring cities and indeed
neighboring towns
in their
development plan you can tell a story
right now as an example
why not you know newcastle is doing well
sunderland
is just uh beginning to go
through the motions and the same is true
as of hull as well
if you think about
you know a northeast cluster that ran
right from the borders
right down to the wash
a super cluster of clean green energy
nissan vision in sunderland
brit fault
in blythe offshore wind
in hull and that would then scoop up and
encompass a whole range of cities and
towns
some currently doing okay indeed well in
the case of newcastle some doing rather
less well uh hull and sunburn that for
me is the next step to go from cluster
to supercluster and that's a lesson
that internationally stands out very
clearly that's why we have
the silicon valley super cluster that's
why we have the boston mit
supercluster we don't have superclusters
other than london right now
and that is one of the agendas of the
future i think
well wouldn't one of the if we were
going to go that way i mean what marks
out london and the south east or even
just the greater london or the m25 area
of london is scale you know it's a big
labor market it could be 10 more 12
million people within that people
commute in you can get up to 15 million
people now
if you were able to make a
a a single labor market out of leeds in
manchester or the lead zone verong and
the manchester over you would get a
scale you would get an international
skill there
but we don't seem to have we seem to be
more interested in building high speed
from london to birmingham than from
leeds to manchester which i would have
thought may
in terms of bang for the buck would do
more for the country
than london brum
well i mean two points on that i think
your prognosis is right that you know
you get these real you know supercluster
effects these economies of scale
with population masses i reckon that are
you know at or around five million or
more
and the reason was looking to group
together
cities and towns
and think of them in a regional terms is
precisely to get to that scale where
those benefits are largest and kick in
but i mean
in some ways you know
coverts had huge numbers of downsides
one of the positives though
has been that your physical proximity
is no longer so essential essentially
physical infrastructure is somewhat less
important although still important for
many
uh digital infrastructure is just as
important so to some extent that
connectivity that connective tissue
these days
could be as much digital uh as it is
uh physical so you know as you know
there is a big infrastructure plan
underway that will do a much better job
of connecting
uh than in
the past if you ask people actually what
they want from infrastructure they don't
want high-speed rail from leeds to
birmingham
they want decent local buses they want
cycleways they want a decent local metro
system and that i think will be
made good on and that plus improved
digital infrastructure broadband gigabit
i think gives us a chance of making good
on those
city-wide clusters i mentioned earlier
on i mean see that you you used several
times the word cluster
because the there's been a long-running
debate in regional policy among
academics and and politicians
about whether it's the cluster approach
or whether it is effectively just
coloring in the map because there was a
big voice for cluster in the 60s and 70s
the problem with the cluster approach
which i instinctively feel is looking at
international instruments is the right
ways but almost by definition if you're
going for clusters
the places not in the cluster and are
the ones that are going to lose out and
politicians found it more easily just to
color in the map so
from the 60s onwards actually going back
to the 30s you began to talk about
special development areas and then
development areas and then not so
development areas but everybody had to
have a share of the pie and in the end
if everybody's a special development
area north of watford it's not really
the original policy and
i mean when i was involved in advising
government this i used to argue for
caster policy but the politicians hate
it because well that wouldn't include my
time i'm not we're not going to be in
that we want to be a special development
area
that must still be a problem
i think it is but here's the word cast
the problem um
you know not everywhere
uh
can be a cluster uh for all the reasons
you say uh and in fairness not
everywhere wants to be a cluster
uh i i do think you that they are we
know they are the wellspring
uh of productivity and pay and economic
activity and have a real virtue and
value
equally we know uh that for some people
and for some places
you know what they want for their area
uh isn't necessarily
uh those jobs that congestion um
that degree of agglomeration
if if you like so i think everywhere
needs something
but it's not the same thing you know for
some people uh it is green space for
some people it's the absence
of a commute and what we find of course
is that levels of your well-being
tend to be
higher
in those rural places than they are in
the city
clusters i think everywhere needs
something but it's not the same thing
not everyone needs to be a cluster not
everyone wants to live in a cluster
but we need an agenda and i think the
white paper had this
that does say
you know
there's potential to be
gained within clusters within cities but
equally needs to be an offering for
those
uh in stranded towns
uh and in rural retreats as well it's
just a different sort of offering and
that's where you know social
infrastructure
rather than physical infrastructure uh
comes into play
well i want to come along to social
instruction infrastructure in a minute
but just to put this
a general point to you i mean as i look
around
i still struggle to find
real successes of regional policy that
have really moved the dial i can see
where it's you know you can visit places
uh
the the city center the west end of
glasgow you can see a huge change there
i mentioned manchester the center of
newcastle of course center of
birmingham's transformed as well as
liverpool there are good examples these
cities have a vibrancy about them but
i've also i'll never forget going to
a steel plant just outside naples
because part of the italian government
then had been to move steel to a part of
the country that had never made steel
before and that steel plant on a
beautiful beach was now lying derelict
it was just rusting
uh there i remember
the tory government under harold
macmillan that when it didn't do well in
the 59 landslide panicked and suddenly
forced hillman to move its car
production to just outside glasgow which
had never made cars and of course that
the workers all came from the ship yards
brought in all the restrictive practices
and that was bust
but within 10 15 years too
whereas when i look at the successes
and
it is america which is different where
is booming at the moment where is really
where are people
not leaving but going to florida texas
colorado arizona new mexico
and they're going there not because of
regional policy or leveling up they're
going there because
they've made themselves a really
attractive place to go they've got great
universities they have an
entrepreneurial culture they have
government that is welcoming to to go
there um
i don't see that happening here
well i think that's exactly the model we
should be aspiring to andrew i mean
perhaps there are relatively few
uh at the moment uk examples uh quite on
that scale and of that uh scope i do
think there are success stories you've
mentioned several
uh of them you mentioned
birmingham west midlands that has been
going through the gears at a rate of
knots the same is true of manchester
over somewhat longer
uh time horizon uh t side
we see having turned the decisive
quarters the cities you mentioned
uh that i think in many cases you do you
go there and you do the crane count and
you speak to local leaders and you can't
sense uh anything but a sense of uh them
being
uh on the uh even sunderland
which is the place of my birth
where's up well a month ago now
uh that's been you know as you know
in in secular decline for at least
uh 50 years there's just the earliest
stage
signs and for all the
examples you gave of government policy
uh gone wrong but i mean in sunderland's
case
the one real success uh story throughout
that period is nissan
uh and nissan existing in in sunderland
was an act of strategic government
policy in the early 1980s as you know
[Music]
under margaret thatcher uh exactly so
you know i i
for me um it will be the case that that
more strategic approach to place that
more strategic approach to industry
doesn't always work
but equally we've seen that benign
neglect
uh doesn't work either so it's moving to
a slightly more front foot activist
strategic approach to rebuilding place
is for me absolutely the right way that
that ought not to involve heavy-handed
government this is that empowering
enabling strategy
that provides local leaders of the
powers and local businesses with the
means to make good i mean if there is a
lesson from international experience
including those you mentioned for me
it's that one
is there a danger that in doing this i
think there's a huge political consensus
that you know we need to
we need to be a more equal country in
the sense of the the the the the
inequality between regions should be a
lot less you know we know it's
it is
maybe improbable that the north will
ever be as rich as london and the south
east that but it could be
a lot less poor compared to london and
the south east london is suey generous
it's a it's a international it's a
global city-state so
the only one we have
there it's all it's on its own probably
with new york in the global stage at the
moment
but is there a danger of them trying to
do this that we we we forget
that i mean the one area that does
generate a surplus in our country is
london and the southeast and in many
ways it's funds help to go to pay for
everything else and
should we not be concerned that the
government
i'm told has shelved its plans uh to
turn the oxford cambridge arc
which was to be into sort of world-class
science arc which which um i mean both
universities are are
globally in the top five anyway
wouldn't
should we not still be building on that
or in another plan which was the the
oxford cambridge london triangle uh as
well which which has a world-class
potential and i guess yeah we should do
that but on the other hand it is more
money for london and the southeast it
says kind of dilemma yeah
there is something of a dilemma there um
i mean it's it will be
uh an active cell active self-sabotage
uh to not continue to invest
uh in you know in our real assets
uh and there are huge assets uh in the
places you mentioned whether that be uh
in london
or in the uh so-called uh golden
triangles a golden triangle
uh and the universities that are such a
fertile ground
uh for r d and future business and uh
jobs and and that would be
a self-defeating strategy no one is in
favor of that that i've come across
that is not for my money
inconsistent
uh with still having a somewhat more if
you like you know polycentric model of
growth
where as we say in the white paper
actually
um
more than one part of the uk
has a genuinely
globally uh competitive city or cities
often underpinned by the same
infrastructure that underpins the
success of london and the golden
triangle that is to say
very active and very outward looking
universities uh very active and outward
looking businesses like bae systems
uh world-class
uh schools and research institutes and
infrastructure that that for me is not
an inherent inconsistency i mean
interestingly interestingly
um what we find right now in the uk is
that the spatial disparities that are so
large
between say you know london and
elsewhere
that they're working to this
disadvantage not just for the poorer
places
but for the richer ones as well despite
being top
by some margin
of the pay and productivity league table
in the uk
london is still resounding at the bottom
of the well-being league table and
that's because of overpriced and over
congested
transport and houses and the absence of
green spaces and all of the rest
so funnily enough
some degree
of relocation
of resources works not just for places
catching up
but even for those places that have been
uh thriving ahead over the past several
decades
now it's an interesting point
let me finish with
on this one you you mentioned at the
start of how the the stars are lying
there are a number of things happening
that that that made you hopeful uh for
the leveling up initiative um
perhaps one of the stars that hasn't
aligned at least in the short term will
make it more difficult is uh inflation
which is uh how can i put this
diplomatically it turned out not to be
as transient as
some central bankers would have had us
believe
but i don't want to that's an interview
for another day with you and other uh i
know you're a former central bank and
now but the the consequence of that in
the cost of living
is that a number of people are going to
find that their benefits are not going
to be rising as fast as prices even big
wage increases these days and people are
getting bigger ones they've had for a
while are struggling to keep pace with
the cost of living isn't that at least
in the short term going to be another
setback
for
the regions the areas that we're trying
to level up
i think it will i mean just on your
earlier point as a former central banker
even actually when i was a former
central banker
andre i remember giving an interview
uh with fraser and k in this building uh
to them and um for warning of some if
not exactly all of what is now
uh playing out across the global economy
inflation-wide i wish i had been wrong
but it turns out i was
uh more right than than i wanted will
that be a headwind yes it will
um
uh and that will that headwind will be
felt most forcefully
uh by those on uh on titus budgets and
that will
therefore be a step backwards
on uh leveling up rather than a step
forwards i think that is uh true
and my central view would be that those
inflationary pressures
will prove um even more persistent
uh than would currently be the central
view i think of of many including uh
many central banks the truth is this
isn't just an energy story it's it's
well
past being an ng story the price of
pretty much everything
is going up at the moment or whether
that's food or goods or services or
indeed the the cost of people in the
form of
wages i suspect it's a headwind that'll
be large and relatively
uh persistent my hope and of course at
this stage you could be no more than
hope
is that that that will not set
as too far back
uh
on the leveling up front indeed that it
might even fortify
politicians and policy makers to push on
and make good on these 20
30 missions time will tell but hope
springs eternal
that's very very sense but it's a good
point to end on uh andy listen thank you
so much uh for giving us your time uh
for this spectator tv event with british
airspa
um i've been a joy to talk to you
i have not read all 325 pages
but i will because that's just how geeky
i am and
i hope to be talking to you again about
this it's a program i think that goes
beyond politics and is something that
the whole country
wants to see happening to see the
leveling up so more power to your elbow
andy halden and thank you for joining us
this morning on spectator tv
thank you very much
now that was andy haldane let's go now
to the chairman of bae systems so roger
carr an old friend of
spectator tv and the magazine and has
done several events in the past with us
he's waiting to talk to us now so let's
go straight to them roger it's all yours
andrew thank you so much and uh it's
really good to be partnering again with
spectator um and just to say to andy
thank you so much for that address this
morning as always clear well-structured
very thoughtful and i think really
defines both the challenge and the
possible solutions to what is really a
major problem for this country and for
other parts of the world too
so there's no doubt that the principle
of leveling up um naturally appeals to
all our sense of fairness in opportunity
life quality
wealth creation and indeed when we look
at it in the broad it is a mission that
we can all applaud
but the delivery of the mission and i
think andy made this point you know
requires government and business working
together in lockstep
certainly to set the right climates
through education policy taxation
support and occasionally direction
business i feel to harvest the
opportunities that government offers
and commit to education to training
to investment and productivity to
fulfill customer needs yes
but but to do so by leveraging talents
that are
nationwide now it is clearly an economic
and social imperative to create a
society
that is at ease with itself
and to ensure it is achieved not by
redistribution
of the current pie
but by changing the leadership mindsets
and indeed the employees skill sets
to make the pie bigger
and the share more widely and fairly
distributed
now of course efforts to support
leveling up has already been said this
morning um are not new successive
governments have attempted over the last
50 years or so to address the
concentration of wealth and
opportunities that are mainly in london
and our major cities
i think from a company point of view we
at bae systems have been continually
getting on
with the leveling up agenda in our own
business
delivering
social value and making a significant
and positive impact
in the regions and communities where we
operate and we've been doing this
for a very long time
in fact because of the historic and
regional location of the sites
we do know these issues well
and we know
that bespoke
and regional specific solutions
if you like the
clusters and superclusters
they are ultimately the answer to the
success of this type of project
now ba systems is best known of course
for the significant role we do play in
keeping our country safe
and it's something of which we are
extremely proud
the work that we do
developing very advanced technologies
products and services
they enable governments and the armed
forces and security services to defend
the freedoms and liberties of people
around the world and that supports the
international stability that we all see
is very important and ultimately keeping
people safe
but the economic value
of defence and security that brings to
all the communities in which we operate
is often overlooked
as a company we have an extensive
footprint in the uk with 50 sites
including in scotland the north west the
south of england as well and wales
our work is making a positive social and
economic contribution
through long-term
high quality employment
supply chains yes and driving vital
investment
in research and development
in all of those places
so look here are a few facts as
highlighted in the recent independent
report on ba systems prepared by
oxford economics
in the uk alone we contributed more than
10 billion to gdp in 2020
around 4 billion to exports
supporting a total tax contribution
approaching 3 billion and supporting
143 000 full-time jobs across the uk
and we also spent just under 4 million
with more than 5 000 suppliers right
across the uk
so when we when we think of our role in
leveling up more than 40 percent of our
uk workforce comes from
the most economically challenged local
authorities
and in 2020
we spent nearly 700 million pounds
with suppliers in these areas
our presence in these regions is driving
much needed growth
and that supports the government's
leveling up agenda
in barrow and finesse where we build
submarines for the royal navy
we employ more than a quarter of the
working population
and this brings with it an enormous
responsibility which we take very
seriously
we've worked with the finesse academy
over many years to help drive up
education standards for younger people
in the town
we're also working with partners to
improve the local area including the
creation of an entirely new 10 and a
half million
learning quarter with a university
campus
so whether it's in cumbria lancashire
scotland wales or in the south of
england
our workforce is and must be
both highly skilled
and productive
more than two-thirds of our people in
the uk are employed in
engineering-related roles they support
programs like astute and dreadnought
major submarine programs the future
combat air system or type 26 frigates
the future of the royal navy
of very advanced warships that are going
to be valuable for many years to come
now the technical nature of their work
results in an average productivity of
about 83 000 pounds per employee
and that's almost 30 percent higher
than the average across the
uk and because it takes decades to build
the skills we need
we continually invest in the skills and
capabilities of our workforce
we spend almost 100 million pounds in
skills training and development
every year
and we've built our own skills academies
directly adjacent to our facilities at
samsberry and lancashire in barrow and
finesse in cumbria and in portsmouth in
hampshire at a cost of more than 50
million pounds
we've got nearly 3 300 apprentices and
graduates in training in the uk
at this time
and that ensures a robust pipeline of
talent for the future
and by the way it is essential that
government and industry do everything in
their power to ensure apprenticeships
are no longer viewed as a second class
achievement against a university degree
but an achievement in its own right to
deliver a productive
and valued member of the business
community
in the short term
this year we're recruiting our largest
intake of apprentices and graduates ever
with almost
1700 places available which is about 25
more than last year
and we've also delivered nearly 700 work
experience placements to disadvantaged
young people in a program called
movement to work which is run by the
princess trust
in barrow we've offered more than 180
placements to young unemployed people
and around two-thirds of them have gone
on to take up apprenticeships with us
and just a note to government here the
apprenticeship levy is still not
entirely fit for purpose and it does
need revisiting if we are to encourage
more apprenticeships in this country to
develop the skill set of the nation
now the jobs required for leveling up
must be
sustainable and they must be of high
quality
and in this respect the work we do
directly supports the government's
aspiration for the uk
to be a global leader in technology
and we keenly feel the responsibility we
have to harness our leading
technological capability worldwide
our military aircraft facility in
wharton lancashire is a case in point
here through team tempest we are
developing
both an advanced military aircraft and a
factory of the future
which contains prototypes of the most
advanced manufacturing aerospace
technologies
and we're doing this in conjunction with
some 50 organizations
including the universities of manchester
and sheffield
of course we haven't developed these
skills and technological capabilities in
isolation
we work closely with our partners often
with organizations such as the local
enterprise partnerships catapults
and local and district councils
organizations
which share the same aims as bae systems
to see the regions thrive and prosper
good example is our participation in a
pilot trailblazer in cumbria for an
employer-led approach to skills planning
and this is to support the department
for education in determining how best to
roll out local skills improvement plans
right across the country
these plans are intended to provide a
clear articulation of employees needs
as well as delivering the changes
required to help employers acquire the
skills
that they need and ultimately boost
productivity
and beyond the uk we have significant
operations in europe the middle east
asia and australia all committed to
doing the same thing with equal
enthusiasm
beyond the economic value we deliver we
are clear about the role we play in
supporting the communities where we
operate
and i want to give you just a few
examples of of walking the talk
in portsmouth we donated 250 000 pounds
that will fund two new hubs
to allow voluntary sector organizations
to share facilities
reduce costs and to collaborate on
projects
in rochester in kent we donated a
hundred thousand pounds to the royal
british legion centenary village it's a
project for disadvantaged military
veterans
in barrow 2 we are supporting community
resilience hubs
and funding a counselling service with
the cumbria alcohol and drugs advisory
service
outside bishop stockton near glasgow for
example we have developed
780 acres of former brownfield land that
were munition manufacturing sites at one
time into a completely new town
of 4 000 homes and a school and this is
called dargavel village
and these are just a few examples which
reflect our strong corporate commitment
to the esg agenda
so in closing i i believe that the key
to leveling up as i've illustrated is
not some centrally controlled master
plan and that's i think exactly the
point andy made earlier
but it is the development of regional
and bespoke solutions
by the people who actually live and work
in those regions
ensuring
business and government act on advice
from those who truly understand the real
needs of the communities
in which they live
and as i said at the start
if we are to turn
a working ambition
into a practical achievement
this is the time
where business and government
must be in lockstep
to think nationally yes but act locally
to deliver a fairer more prosperous
and equitable
society thank you so much andrew over to
you
roger thank you uh for that uh very much
uh it sounds that the government's
leveling up strategy has no chance uh
unless it has companies like yours on
its side so thank you for explaining
what you're doing for being with us this
morning and for being our partner for
this leveling up of event
both andy and roger have raised many
issues right at the heart of the the
building opportunity program
beyond london and the southeast so we
have more to talk about we're not going
to go to a panel and to share that let
me hand over now to the editor of the
spectator fraser nelson fraser is still
yours
i think you need to unmute fraser
right thank you andrew and now after
roger's comments we're going to drill a
little bit more into the idea of
leveling up and look at these
apprenticeships and bae um takes on
something like a thousand apprentices
every year but is that reflective of a
national picture and what is the health
or otherwise of that picture and so
roger is going to stay with us in the
panel but i'm also joined by alex
burkhart who's a minister for skills who
oversees apprenticeships and my
colleague isabel hardman um alex
burkhart let's start with you i mean the
government is imposing an apprenticeship
levy quite a significant chunk of of
extra tax on on corporates and corporate
profits but if you look at the number of
people in apprenticeships has been going
down
over the years so of course lockdown is
part of that but is there calls for
alarm is this is this something an
agenda which is in retreat rather than
expanding
uh hi fraser thank you very much for
inviting me to be part of this panel
today
apprenticeship's absolutely not in
retreat and i think some of the
confusion around the figures uh
originates from the fact that
about five years ago now the government
reformed the whole apprenticeship scheme
because it felt that the standard of a
lot of apprenticeships was not up to
scratch and yeah
we were finding that there were a lot of
people on apprenticeships who did not
know that they were apprentices and so
we created these uh new more robust
standards um which did see a decline in
the number but an increase in the
quality and since that time you know uh
we've seen uh we've seen good numbers
and uh we are now uh right now uh we are
back to uh above our pre-pandemic levels
so we are not
upward trajectory uh we have uh and we
have a lot of young people
who are getting great opportunities with
companies like
sir rogers
and finding that alternative route to
employment to skilled employment
outside of uh of a university education
that's one of the things that i'm very
very interested in because i think for
for a long time certainly since at least
the days
of tony blair
the um the whole post 18 agenda has
really been framed in term of terms of
university or not
uh and it's time to it's time to shrug
that off
because with our degree level
apprenticeships um you know for those
people who speak uh qualification ease
these are level six qualifications yeah
a level is level three
uh degrees uh a level six with uh level
six degree level uh apprenticeships uh
we are seeing young people build
very exciting careers with good salaries
in companies that
are part of our of our leveling up
agenda and what i'm you know what i
really want to see over the course of
the next few years
is this sort of new uh meaningful
pathway
for people leaving formal education to
move into so uh you'll have a chunk of
people going to university you'll have a
chunk of people doing uh apprenticeships
and moving straight into work on the job
training and you'll also have some
people who who leave and go straight
into work um and we know that there's an
enormous appetite for this because ucas
this year
uh opened about 750 000 accounts um you
know uh was about normal
but this year they asked everyone
whether they would be interested in
taking an apprenticeship route and
almost half of the people almost half of
the people uh who opened an account with
you said yes
and you're you just see this appetite
uh emerging in the next generation for
um you know for for a new way of doing
things for a chance to go straight into
work learn on the job build up your
networks build up your experiences um
whilst getting a formal uh qualification
as part of it no debt chance to get you
know three years ahead of your uh your
peers in the workplace uh this is these
are really exciting offers and it's the
job of uh government now uh to uh to
grow these uh grow these
opportunities now so roger you mentioned
in your remarks earlier that an
apprenticeship is no longer seen as
second-class status to a university
degree now that might be true for one of
bae's coveted apprenticeships but isn't
it the case that there's still a wide
range of quality of apprenticeships so
the word itself is not quite equivalent
to a degree and alex berkard just told
us that one of his problems was not that
there were too many apprenticeships but
there were too few of good quality and
there were people being badged as
apprentices who didn't even know that
they had the status there seems to be
rather a lot of confusion in recent
years about what an apprentice is and
what an apprentice should be
well i think the point is is fair fraser
and i i think it's sad that that some of
the the lower level so-called
apprenticeships degrade what is a very
high quality experience at the the true
level of apprenticeships the sort the
bae but not only bae
give as opportunities to young people so
i think part of this is is the way it is
presented i mean it is important that
apprenticeships are seen
genuinely as an equal pathway to a
career success than simply the second
grade pathway and the point i tried to
make was in fact i think we still have a
social hurdle to overcome in getting
that fully acknowledged so that there's
a a government and an industry job in
promoting what high quality
apprenticeships do for the opportunities
of young people there is the economic
benefit clearly of getting wonderful
training and not carrying a burden of
debt
there is being an immediate contributed
society and also having a long-term job
capability that that providing you
continue to learn and upgrade your
skills is something that lasts you a
lifetime now these messages are made
they need to be made with greater
emphasis and the system of the levy
which has been improved since its
original announcement still needs some
adjustment to encourage the right kind
of apprenticeships to be made
and funded accordingly so a little too
much money probably at the moment goes
into what i would call advanced
management training which is really not
what the levy was about and more focus
needs to be on those skills that are
vital to the economy and therefore
businesses encouraged to spend more to
do just that but your point is is valid
quality presentation of quality and
embedding that into the society's view
of an apprenticeship is something we all
have a job to do
isabel um
can you say a bit more about how this
agenda is perceived within governments i
mean quite often i hear tory mps almost
joke with themselves and nobody quite
understands what leveling up means
apprenticeships have been something
which both parties have dealt with we
had tony blair a few days ago saying he
wanted 70 of young people to go to
university rather than fifty percent
that seems to be him tugging in the
other direction alex burkhart here told
us in the speech recently that he would
be happy if fewer people went to
university more people went to
apprenticeships do you sense a is there
a party political division in this
agenda and do you do you sense that the
conservatives are coming to believe that
there is more meat on this kind of
verbal bone which boris johnson threw at
them when he started talking about
leveling up first of all
yes i think if there's a
a word that's even less understood than
uh leveling up in westminster it's
skills and when i was on my way over
here um to do this event i bumped into a
fellow lobby journalist and when i told
him i was doing a panel about skills he
chuckled because it's one of those areas
that that the westminster bubble tends
to ignore and it's it's such sharp
contrast
to the way in which skills and
apprenticeships are discussed on the
doorstep in the wider world i mean if
you talk to conservatives who are out
about campaigning uh over the past well
decade really they'll say that
apprenticeships is one of the things
that is like gold dust on the political
doorstep and that's why there's been an
increasing focus on them in recent years
it was very interesting to hear the
minister explaining why there had been
such a drop
in recent years i think the number of
people starting each year falling from
500 000 in six 2016 17 to just 323 000
but if there's an increase in quality
as he claims then actually you're
probably more likely to to get an
increase in appreciation of that in a
political
setting as well i think the leveling up
white paper more widely was um quite
unfairly caricatured actually in
westminster everyone focused on the um
the esoteric bits of it about jericho
rather than the very thoughtful and
broad assessment it gave not just of
what leveling up is and obviously that
that is a there's a long list in there
but also of why previous governments
have failed to do this
the problem that i encounter when i'm
talking to conservative mps and
ministers in private is that
while they might be signed up in
principle to leveling up once they've
worked out what it means and once
they've waded through the document
they're not entirely sure that this
government is is the one that's going to
be able to deliver it for the political
problems that we're very
aware of uh it's it's not just that
there's uh potentially a lack of
bandwidth at the top there's also a lack
of money which was reflected in the way
the white paper um was written and has
been reflected again in the discussions
in cabinet um this week you had um also
a contradiction i think between some of
the
uh commitments uh in the white paper and
political reality michael gove is
obviously the the lead on this but he's
also the person who has pulled back from
the government's controversial planning
reforms and that was something there was
sniping about in cabinet again
it's something that previous governments
have failed to deliver because it is
really hard and it's one of those things
that you need such a relentless focus on
delivery on that i'm not entirely sure
is is present even in the government
with with this majority at this stage
well we're going to have neil o'brien a
leveling up minister and coming on after
the end of this panel to tell us more
about that white paper and the ideas
inside this but um of course anybody
watching this can contribute to if you
want to leave a question you can do so
under the um there's a box under the
video saying ask a question if you click
that ask a question and i will put it to
our panelists um later on but alex
burkhart let's go back to you meanwhile
and how are we supposed to keep track of
the success or otherwise of
apprenticeships if you say we shouldn't
be looking at the number we should be
looking at the quality something tells
me you don't publish figures for how
many of these apprenticeships you regard
as being good quality
or not sorry phrase i think you
misunderstood what i said in my previous
comment please reformed uh
apprenticeship standards you know four
or five years ago and since then we have
uh we are very much assured that
everyone doing an apprenticeship is
doing a high quality apprenticeship so
this oh you half a million figure from
five six years ago that is banded around
that figure in at that time we weren't
assured of quality and that's why we
took the reforming steps we did but this
is part of a package
of change in the skills agenda which is
is very deep and far-reaching
what we're doing is we're putting
employers in the driving seat of our
skills programs and what that means is
we have apprenticeship standards
set with employers we are having a new
generation of technical qualifications t
levels equivalent of a levels in
technical education which are again
being designed with employers and then
we're doing the same thing at technical
qualifications at level two which is the
equivalent of gcse
and what that will do is mean it will
mean that for young people they will
know
that they are studying qualifications
designed with employers that are going
to give them the skills the economy
needs
and this is this is a major step forward
in a guaranteeing quality but also
making sure that employers can have
confidence that the qualifications taken
by people in college or perhaps even
slightly later in life uh are going to
do the job uh when uh when they hire
people so
this is part of a really um i think a
really exciting
program of change and one that was
backed by the chancellor at the autumn
statement where we had we had the best
um uh spending um settlement for uh on
skills for uh for over a decade uh and
um you know i uh as you go around the
country at the moment as i've had the
privilege to do it the past seven months
in this job
i you realize that
i don't think there's ever been in my
lifetime
such an appetite
for skills um you're seeing
employers who you need to hire going
into further education colleges and
having those conversations about the
skills they need and i you know i think
part of this is is down to um down to
brexit um i think that for a long time a
lot of companies
were hiring skilled labour from abroad
they didn't need to take such an
interest in what
what's happening in terms of homegrown
talent but now those conversations have
begun and um and yeah one of the things
in what andy was saying which is
particularly pertinent to my brief
um is
is how we we need to change
um uh local leadership and local
governance not just in terms of
political leadership which is
important but also in terms of how we
are bringing other stakeholders into the
conversation so if the first part of my
work is is making sure that we have good
standards which are backed by employers
the other part of it is making sure that
we have
local skills priorities set by employers
and yeah this is at the heart of our
local skills improvement plans you get
local employers together who uh say to
uh you know colleges and other skills
providers these are the skills we need
in order to take our businesses to the
next level and i've
one of the most uh exciting things i've
seen in the job uh was the other day
where we had uh yeah we had a local
government come down from t site
department for education
uh with um the local colleges
and bp
and what's happening up there
is that t side are providing the the
land for
bp to
to set up its hydrogen work you know
state of the art green technology
and bp are also backing
the local colleges to get them the
skills to train local people to do those
jobs in the growing and new economy and
t site and it's that partnership you
know between government local government
between business
and between local colleges
that are going to regenerate uh these
areas uh you know helping local people
power um local economies and yeah it's
that for me is leveling up
okay now the questions are beginning to
come in now i've got one here from
aleister dick he's picking up in the
points that alex burkhart made there
about brexit his question is to you sir
roger is whether
anything you've seen has led you to
believe that brexit has been a factor in
encouraging the upskilling of them of
british workers either in the ae's
experience or more nationally is brexit
something which you've noticed moving
the dial in any way
i think i can only speak for bae and and
i think we've had a policy
free brexit host brexit
of investing in developing training so
that we can build our own talent
pipeline and secure ourselves for the
future and let me say in so doing of
course some of those people go into
supply chain industries and help them
too so
it's had no impact at all i i think
what we can all see however is unless
this country is really skilled
its ambition to be globally competitive
i mean is simply an ambition it it must
be underpinned by education i agree
entirely with what alex just said you
know the the joined up positioning of
government and industry to determine
what is required as well as how it can
be delivered is mission critical
and i think equally departments within
government need the same sense of
bonding
so that treasury sees something like the
levy as a genuine way of helping
apprenticeships develop rather than
simply another form of tax revenue and i
think we've moved on in recent years to
do that i think that the department of
education
in addressing t levels in making sure
that schools are teaching subjects that
are going to be valuable for the long
term economic strength of this country
is a very important element and we need
to do more i.t work because the whole
take-up of it subjects has gone down
rather than up we need to encourage more
of that we need to embed in the thinking
of schools and colleges that
apprenticeships are a very worthwhile
and high quality way of developing for a
life career experience all of these
things need to be joined up if we are to
shift
to where we need to be for long-term
global success and there is evidence
that it's happening but the pace of
change and the degree of in commitment
to it has to increase as well
and alex burkhart let's pick up one of
those um points from sir roger i mean
then if the treasury is
imposing
an apprenticeship levy is that money
really being transferred when i was i
was looking earlier on to see if i could
find out if employers are spending more
money on off-the-job uh training and the
figures i came across just as figures
actually gone down from 2017 to 2019 by
the tune of about 2 billion quid i mean
are there more encouraging figures
somewhere saying that employers are
spending more on this training because
so far um it seems that there's not much
evidence of this obvious dividend
passing through to the people who need
the skills
so the apprenticeship levy
is working that it's creating high
quality apprentices and we are seeing um
growing numbers in exactly the right
areas that we want however
um yeah fraser you will have heard the
um chancellor say in his may's lecture
and
again in the spring statement that he
wanted to
examine whether the current system
of taxation
including the operation of the
apprenticeship levy is doing enough to
incentivize businesses to invest in the
right kinds of training so you know
the treasury is um uh yeah is alive to
this broader issue uh and yeah we're
we're part of those uh uh conversations
with them at the moment
but i must come back to the fact that we
have uh yeah we have a growing number of
high quality apprentices that are
leading to
really good careers for uh for young
people at the moment and creating that
um alternative path for them
okay and another quick question for you
alex and one from sophie fitton do you
have any thoughts on investing pensions
into leveling up the um productive
financing as the treasury calls it
sorry phrase could you repeat that so
and what about trying to um investing
pensions into leveling up funds and
there are and there's such a phrase as
productive financing and so there are
there are ways of being able to produce
and you know money that people invest in
pensions and and and investing them into
areas that you might regard as
productive it's a very interesting idea
i think probably neil uh who will come
on uh later would be better uh better
place to answer that price straight into
into pension policy but um but no uh an
interesting point okay and we've got a
question here for you isabel this is um
and this is from michael keegan and it's
do you
do you get a sense of there being like
if there's a change of government does
everything change i mean if a five-year
plan is needed is there any chance of
this there might be a general election
next year government sem chop and change
over this is there a sense that what is
agreed now
might still be existing in two or three
years time or
is this an area of consensus otherwise
or is it an area of party political
division
i think
i think the importance of investing in
skills is always something that both
parties will
will pay well hopefully more than lip
service too but just looking back over
uh previous attempts at leveling up sort
of going more widely than skills uh if
you look at what happens when a
long-term program
is cancelled by an incoming new
government
that can lead to huge um
uh not just dissatisfaction but i think
a sense of uh being abandoned so for
instance what i was a housing journalist
when i started out and i covered the
housing market renewal programme uh
that the labour government that john
prescott were um particularly keen on
that was a 15-year program um and the
conservatives you know as was their
right came in and cancelled it halfway
through that 15-year program and i went
to stoke which was one of the housing
market renewal pathfinder areas and
it had been devastated both by
that program demolishing streets ready
to rebuild new nicer houses but also by
the cancellation of that programme with
streets that had already been demolished
that were now not going to be um rebuilt
and so there are real consequences to
this uh to these chopping and changing
policies but you know this is our
political cycle and you can't tie the
hands of the next government on a policy
that that that would be the the wrong
thing to do one other concern that i
have um
is
and it's it's been wonderful hearing
about barrow which is a place that i
spend a lot of time in my my home there
looks out over the devonshire dot cool
and you know the character of the town
is is
so shaped by uh bae and by the shipyards
um but it's really interesting looking
more widely at the local leadership
there so if you compare
city uh devolution to city areas to
manchester which is always the example
that is cited and compare it to cumbria
um there's just a it's very difficult to
translate devolution to cities to a
wider
area like cumbria and indeed it's
something that
ministers have in the past sort of
slightly given up on so when it was not
levelling up but the northern powerhouse
some of those documents actually forgot
to mention cumbria um because there was
such a focus on on the more urban areas
and i think that leads to to a number of
things and as a result of a number of
things partly um the contrast in the
quality of local political leadership
between manchester for instance
liverpool for instance and then cumbria
um towns like barrow where
you know the the cat it's probably fair
to say that the the council does not
have the same uh
level of skills or political might as
manchester um and i'm not entirely sure
from my reading of the leveling up white
paper and from conversations with uh mps
in these non-city areas
how that's going to be resolved
okay
and so roger i mean i think bae employs
something like quarter of the working
age population in barrow and fairness
you just say you're a big employer
there's a bit of an understatement i
think i'm writing saying that 40 as well
are from
underprivileged backgrounds so you know
it's kind of case study and what the
government wants more of but i'm
interested and you were saying earlier
that you're doing basically brexit
hasn't influenced cbae one way or the
other you're doing what you do because
you want to do it and you have to do it
i'm wondering have any of the recent
government policies changed what you do
because a business like yours is always
going to be you know it's going to stand
out it's one of the bigger investors and
people one of the bigger
employer trainers and is there anything
you you're doing that you would not have
been doing have the government's
policies been different
no not not fundamentally i mean i think
some of the policies are encouraging i
think the levy as it's developed has
been an encouragement for all training
um
and one would support that and also the
the further development of it to
encourage more high quality training
but but i think what has happened is the
government's positioning on levelling up
and the fact that it became a core celeb
and something that that is printed and
spoken of on a regular basis
it has helped us i think reinforce the
messaging in our own communities that
working together you know just as has
been said by others with local
authorities with the leps with the
catapults with central government
working together collectively
is an important part of delivering a
mission that isn't a political mission
it is about a country ultimately
becoming comfortable in its own skin
with itself and and as the world moves
on and competition globally increases
unless we do provide greater opportunity
for people and do help the skills of
people who develop developed this
country is going to fall behind
and that is going to be to no one's
interest so
i i think by highlighting this policy
and in the way that andy did this
morning
and reinforcing the significance of
leveling up as a mission for all not
just for a party is something that we
need to sustain whoever is leading the
country politically because without that
this country will not thrive so i think
business has a real responsibility
to stand proud to invest in people but
to make it publicly known that by
working in partnership everyone benefits
and and while ever levelling up is a key
focal point of this government and
successive governments i think we have
something to build on
okay please keep your questions coming
and there's a chat box under the video
player will ask a question click that
ask a question and i'll do my best to to
ask it so the next one comes from
patricia and it's to you alex burkhart
she's saying that she's struck by what
you're saying about the importance of
vocational training being an alternative
to universities she's saying that
couldn't you have more places offering
vocational training and perhaps call
them polytechnics
i i look that's uh that's a very uh well
put point uh what we're seeing now is um
our excellent fe colleges
our really excellent further education
colleges uh are um are offering uh
training for all the way from kind of
level two uh up to up to level six um
you know so yeah some very um
high tech training
alongside them uh we've created uh
institutes of technology and these are
partnerships uh between uh fe colleges
and he institutions and business people
like siemens and fujitsu and so on
to uh to create that next generation of
very very high-tech skills
um
but yeah i um you know i hope that there
are and i know that there are still some
form of polytechnics
that are also providing um you know very
very good uh technical education and
vocational training
yeah you can see that there um that
there is
more opportunity to do more and you know
in government we're we're always having
conversations with people who want to
partner with us in that
right but one of them might could freiza
could i just
please very good point that alex made i
think which it is
the fact that you know in many ways a
lot of the polytechnics were rebranded
as universities when it became and very
popular to see everybody go to
university the tony blair common which i
i agree has not been helpful in
balancing off the apprenticeship versus
degree achievement but the the core
content of some of those places that
were polytechnics has remained very
soundly based so you know you you can go
to a university which was a polytechnic
and get a very good quality experience
in in subjects that were the the
heartland of polytechnics in the past
and i think the preservation of that
principle is very important for
continued education as we go forward so
forgive me but i just wanted to
emphasize the point that alex made but
one of the problems alex is that say if
somebody's thinking of fam you're
going to either a polytechnic or
university
you're trying to work out you're going
to take on a lot of debt certainly under
this government's policy huge amount of
debt you're going to walk away with
and now of course you might say that
education experience is valuable in and
of itself but there's also another um
question to ask am i ever going to get a
return on this investment how much will
this qualification really get me now for
a long time politicians have been coming
up with average figures saying that the
average graduate make something like a
hundred grand over a lifetime more than
a non-graduate but that figure is deeply
misleading because it factors in lawyers
and doctors it doesn't say if you're
history graduates and well like me for
example is there any real salary premium
probably not
and i keep hearing year after year
politicians saying oh don't worry we're
going to make a data available so you
can look at your individual course and
your individual university and find out
how much of a salary premium or not
their graduates are making but still
it's it's very very difficult to do that
so how are people supposed to work out
if they if they want to get the best
best investment in their money if they
are thinking of borrowing or taking or
even investing the time how much of a
salary premium they can expect where can
they turn what tools are the government
and making available so people can
better make an informed decision well
i'm very grateful to you for that
question uh fraser because later this uh
just after the local elections we had to
get through purdue the government is uh
my department is releasing um the first
set of data for the unit for future
skills uh which is
a unit that has been set up by nadeem
zahawi my my secretary of state and
myself
uh in order to give
more people a better understanding of
where particular courses particular
institutions lead now the first cut of
data won't provide all of that
information we have a lot of refining to
do but we wanted to want to start
getting things out uh rather than making
uh you know the best the enemy of the
good but ultimately where i uh where i
really want us uh to get to is a
position where
uh a young person um or indeed
perhaps somebody who's going back to
retrain later in life
uh can say
this course at this fe college or uh
this university
what did people like me get out of it
and that's not just money money is very
important salary is very important but
it's also
where do they go and work what sort of
career did they build
and
having the information on you know uh
whether particular whether people
studying
health and social care courses in fe
colleges went to work in health and
social care or ended up in retail is
very important for
uh people studying the course it's very
important for the colleges who often
only have this information on um
anecdotal basis and it's very important
for for government and for commissioners
and for ofsted
um and we've never had it before
what we're working towards now i think
is really exciting because uh it will
give
for the first time um prospective
students also their parents um an
insight into the likelihood um that
certain dis that uh uh uh course choices
will give people the sorts of um uh
results they uh they want uh and i think
it has the opportunity to do something
in um in some leveling up areas that i
used to visit when i worked for the
center for social justice
where you would meet people who um who
didn't really believe in the value of
education
because
they saw no evidence that it was making
any difference
when you can just
demonstrate to people
that certain uh certain apprenticeships
certain technical courses certain
degrees
um have a have a real um have had a real
impact on the people who've taken them
um both in their career opportunities uh
and in their their
salary outcomes uh then you start to
give greater confidence in the education
system uh as a whole and i think that
has a real power to be transformative
okay a question here from um james
tullock is for every user roger he's
asking that he's got a 17 year old son
who isn't quite sure what he wants to do
after university what where do you think
are the most the hot tickets as skills
though what to get courses to get if you
wanted to what would it be engineering
would it be maps would it be something
else
what would you point young people
towards now would you the demand and the
supply and demand and disjunction is the
greatest
um i mean there are there is a real um
there's a particular hunger at the
moment for for manufacturing skills and
uh for engineering skills you know we
have we have high vacancies um and and
some really exciting opportunities the
first degree level apprentice i ever met
uh was was in manchester and he was uh
young chap who had left school um good a
level results and he decided not to go
to university and he'd taken up an
apprenticeship at aston martin
and you know it's just a little bit of
you that gets a bit jealous when you see
um someone in that position because
we're a fantastically exciting company
um working um you know on um on the
engineering floor learning from some of
the best in the business um very um you
know very inspiring stuff but it's not
just higher manufacturing i met i met
young people who are now building uh
careers in law
through the apprenticeship group um not
going to university people who are
becoming accountants um you know uh
doing the same thing
uh and um yeah the
the educational landscape the training
landscape
is changing um it's changing before our
eyes okay and so roger what kind of
femme skills do bae are most looking for
if you could get a greater supply of
anybody doing any discipline what would
bae look for but we we encourage right
at the outset of education stem subjects
not not exclusively but recognizing that
the development of those subjects at the
most junior times in education create a
foundation on which then people have
greater choice for ultimate longer term
education careers so i mean we
hands up that's where we encourage
people to look because what we want out
of that are people who have a genuine
interest in the natural aptitude and the
basic learning to do an engineering
skill role
and you know we have
legions of opportunities there in the
organization and as we look to the
future and the way our own technology is
developing you know the opportunities
for those people to have both you know
well-paid but very interesting and
long-term sustainable jobs is very high
so i i would unequivocally encourage
anyone who has the basic attitude and
the fundamental interest of an
engineering career to move in it to that
direction i t is obviously
the digital skill set is something that
everybody is crying out for the war for
talent in that area is very substantial
whether you're in engineering or
consumer goods the digital capability is
vital and we need to do more education
at the basic level for iting skills on
which those later skills are developed
isabelle and this is a question from
um debbie nichols
she's saying that labour party
conference coming up they'll probably be
the last one before the general election
well who knows but it might well be and
you're beginning to hear soundings from
the labour party saying things like for
example they would be doing a version of
michael gove's phrase that overlooked
the undervalued communities that places
like grimsby once powered britain they
could do so again if only the government
would share grimsby's ambition for
itself
it doesn't seem that but labour will
simply do the same agenda perhaps with a
different label in other words is it
more like is it more likely to rebuild
than is to scrap leveling up
yes i think so i think you as you say
you're highly unlikely to see the phrase
leveling up make it into
a labor government department i suspect
that would be one of the things that
they'd um make a big fuss of changing
and if you look at the
the way in which labour engages with
leveling up
uh on a sort of daily basis it tends to
be in a political knockabout uh way just
uh just suggesting it's it's evidence of
of the government sort of floundering
around but actually the the shadow
leveling up secretaries is lisa nandy
and she is somebody who is very much on
board with this agenda in fact she got
mocked roundly in her um leadership bid
for just talking endlessly about towns
it's something that she's been
fascinated by and was on to uh far
before a lot of other politicians that
the need to
work out what to do about left behind
communities particularly
towns and so
what i suspect you're likely to see is
a labour government taking on
a lot of the policies contained within
leveling up giving them its own badge it
would be able to do that as i say with a
fair amount of um credibility given uh
the grounding that it's got with people
like lisa nandy who've been working on
this and if you look at the way that
labour conducts itself
generally a lot of what it does on
policy at the moment
is not to oppose the policy but to say
we would do this better how are
ministers so useless at this this and
this and i i suspect leveling up would
be would be one of those things
and that's roger a question from george
sutherland he says which countries other
than britain are getting this right they
will almost i don't know what french is
for leveling up but i bet that any
country which is trying to deal with the
political headaches that britain has
seen that perhaps led to brexit
the gap in power between
regions and cities has probably got a
similar agenda bae is a global company
who jumps out at you as having a good
balance of being able to get trading and
investment into this area
well i think traditionally i have to say
germany you know set a standard um the
commitment to engineering the commitment
to develop and training
and it did ensure that they had a a wide
population you know ready to take the
advantage of the opportunities that
industry provided in certainly the last
20 years
and and that still exists in the
structure of germany i i think we've
seen
a move towards it in france in australia
there is an increasing belief that
homegrown skills you know having
building things at home by australians
for australians with the training that
will enable them to do that is a growing
commitment of the government and we
we're harvesting that because we now
build you know the equivalent of the
type 26 frigate in australia hunter
class and to do that we require similar
skills of similarly high quality people
you know which have been trained and
developed over a period so we're
starting to see that come through
um but but but germany i think for me
was the original benchmark in focusing
on this as an area of of development and
education and and we have leveraged it
and i think are getting better at it
along with other countries
okay now we've got ten more minutes to
take your questions so and do send them
by clicking the ask a question and
button in the um in the chat box under
the video player and next questions for
for you alex burkhart it's from james
hamilton it is that um do you what would
you judge as success by the next general
election if somebody had to say to you
okay you've been on this job two or
three years
uh you've promised a lot it's election
time now let's see if what you've
delivered what would it be what would
you point to as your definition of
whether you as a minister have succeeded
or failed in this job
i think there's there's a sort of
particularly
poignant episode of yes minister where
people are asked the same thing yeah to
define define the terms of your own
success before you start a project um i
um so there are a number of things we're
working on that we need we need to do
um the first is make sure that the
rollout of t levels uh these uh
technical qualifications that are
equivalent to a level uh that that goes
uh goes to plan we have uh good
projected numbers
we're currently in our second year we
have good projected numbers for our
third year but we have to um keep that
rolling so that it becomes a meaningful
alternative for people at 16 to 18. uh
we have to continue to see growth and
apprenticeships our new reformed uh high
standard apprenticeships and i want to
see
more and more young people leaving
school choosing to do
high quality apprenticeships
rather than
go to university i want that to become a
meaningful choice for people alongside
that um we buy the next election uh or
phrases seem to have insight that the
next election was coming before the
labour party conference in 2023 which uh
uh yes has made me think um but if um uh
um if the if uh the general election is
slightly later than that um i i would
hope to see employer representative
bodies in each area of the country
starting to define um uh local skills
priorities uh that would help colleges
decide which courses they're putting on
for their students uh to help them get
jobs in the local area and as i was
saying earlier it's that
partnership
that is going to
create local growth because it creates
the conditions to attract more
businesses and more investment into
areas and so create local prosperity so
um i think within um the skills
uh um uh policy area we've got a chance
to to really power leveling up in the
in the run-up to the next election
okay
um isabel a question from you from and
james tornas he's saying that what do
you think will be the dividing line
between
the labor and tories on this and it or
will the conservatives
be able to have a distinct agenda was
this that was the them trying to all all
the time
just grab
tory clothing or will there be
will there be something which either
parties can say if you think this is
going to be battleground perhaps it
won't be perhaps you think the political
debate might have moved on to other
things about the next election but when
you think about the battleground states
for example there's lots of red wall
constituencies that voted tory for
brexit and the last time around you
imagine that the leveling up agenda was
in part a kind of tory love letter to
these constituencies saying yes we do
have an agenda for you know former labor
seats and if labor is going to try to
win them back
and then will we be
will we be seeing two competing ways of
doing this or just simply two two words
for the same thing
i suspect it will partly be about
competence for labour on this and they
can tie it very neatly into the cost of
living uh crisis as well and ask the
question of voters does your life feel
better as a result of this lot does your
town look better as a result of this lot
and one of the criticisms of the white
paper is is that it does tend to
go off into a long discussion about sort
of community ties and so on but but
those things are important but also just
the physical
landscape of the town so just to come
back to barrow one of the things that i
always find really striking about barrow
is that um and this is the case for
towns
around the country is people interpret
how well a town is doing based on how
its high street looks now when i talk to
people in barrow they'll say oh the high
street's dead um but actually the town
is booming and you know partly as a
result of bae being being very busy i
was told by someone that i think that
the um the tesco in barrow's got the
largest um selection of taste the
difference or whatever it's called
finest that's it finest vegetables
because the town economy
is booming you probably wouldn't guess
that from the high street but people
still have this relationship with their
local areas that is interpreted through
what is a sort of dying retail sector
which is the high street and that's
that's something that the government is
just not going to solve in time for the
next election it's not going to make
barrow high street feel lively again to
the extent that people start to say our
town is booming even if that is the
reality uh in places like barrow and you
know barrow is as we've discussed today
quite an unusual example in that it has
its
original manufacturing base that the you
know the reason the town exists is the
shipyards it was constructed around the
shipyard there's a lot of towns that
have lost that industry it'll be even
harder for the government uh to give a
sense of of local character to certain
areas in the way that baron furness does
right
now um uh alex um when you when you're
looking at sam okay who knows women next
general election either three and a half
years or four and a half years but you
know the next summer would not exactly
be out of the out of the context
completely there but
you there was a point time where the
conservatives were thinking okay brexit
and labor shortages are going to be a
good thing for us because salary is
going to go up as roughly speaking the
argument was we'll look at these there's
a shortage of truck drivers that's
because truck drivers aren't being paid
enough it's now time to pay and truck
drivers more and this will be a kind of
brexit dividend similar arguments were
of course being being made about skills
you mentioned earlier you think brexit
has been a factor
but i put you it's pretty difficult to
point to many areas where we see either
an increase in salary or a significant
increase in training as a result of
brexit-induced skills shortage and this
particular theory behind brexit
is actually proving not true
um i think that we are in a particularly
difficult situation right now because of
all the extraordinarily terrible things
that are happening uh in eastern europe
i think that that is
um
muddied the economic water what i can
tell you
is that i'm seeing
all across the country
employers
who unlike roger and
bae
have not taken an interest in local
skills starting to do so
and in doing so are helping to create a
new pipeline for young people in uh in
local colleges and local schools uh to
enter um high performing uh british
businesses and that that really is um
even that the start of that dialogue uh
is is a real bonus and it's it's a real
improvement and um and it's going to uh
change the life chances uh of a lot of
people in those areas so you know i i
know that there are um big um big
headwinds at the moment uh but what i'm
starting to see
is the beginning of relationships that
will um outlive those headwinds
well i imagine you'll be hoping those
relationships come to fruition a bit
before the next election but you know
we'll see it might be in two and a half
years as you suggest um who knows i i
didn't suggest anything for him
what it was
i'm not quite sure what it has as a base
case but the
thing is you will give it we're
basically probably more than halfway
right now and people will expect there
to be results right i mean one
parliamentary term
i put to you is enough for voters to
expect results from the promises that
were made in election time
i think voters have have a right to
expect results absolutely um but um
i also uh you know i'm i'm an mp i speak
to a lot of people in my constituency
and they they appreciate that there's
been a pandemic and uh now there's first
major war on european soil since uh 1945
so uh it's not been a normal parliament
uh but um but yes uh yeah of course
voters have a right to expect results
and things uh in my earth certainly i
can see things changing for the better
okay and ms roger a question um to you
from debbie garman and she's struck by
what you're saying about germany and
asks if the federal political structure
in germany contributes to its leveling
up success is it simply the case that in
britain national government is a bit too
big to be um wieldy on this but the
local government is too small and that's
part of the problem
yeah and i think there's been a
recognition that that central government
is not the solution to every problem and
the the devolution of authority
and the empowerment of the regions i
think has been a very positive step
forward
there is no doubt that you have to know
about the local economy in order to have
frankly a sensible solution
in in mind i mean if you see everything
from a remote perspective it's the
equivalent of trying to run a
multinational company from a boardroom
you know anybody that leads you do that
i mean it's not understanding the way
business works it only works by having
very capable people
close to you know the leading edge of
the business where decisions are made
and implemented so
government no different i think we're
seeing definitely a mood of recognition
of that and i think when business picks
up on it and
as i said bob makes the point in barrow
it's a very good example
you know local government business
encouraged by central government have
all fused together to do something to a
community which desperately needed help
in making it a fairer
and more balanced community with
opportunity for all and you know all of
that should transcend party politics i
know it's a naive thing to say but
unless we continue
to have that mindset of improving
opportunity for people in this country
through education and the first part and
business and government working together
thereafter unless we continue with that
mindset we will not really thrive in the
international markets which we will have
to be competitive in the future so i'm
hopeful that whoever's in power however
they rebrand the leveling up principle
the fundamental of leveling up remains
embedded in what we're doing as a nation
if we do not do that
society will not be comfortable with
itself or successful
right and and if i i can put the
question that i put to alex berger to
use her roger what do you think success
looks like do you think it's a scenario
where there are more companies like bae
doing
more of what you're doing in barrow and
fairness would you describe it as um i
don't know narrowing the income
inequality would you describe it as
a narrowing of a skills gap or if so
just to what extent do you think skills
that can be narrowed because there's
been a skills gap for as long as i can
remember in britain and partly because
of immigration has got one of the the
biggest stem skills gaps of any
developed country it's difficult to see
any government closing that but to
wonder how much do you think
realistically can be achieved with them
government policies now
i i think it's you know the principle of
journeys start with one step and
unless we are all focused on doing that
then then the future looks bleak so i
mean do i believe there's a
definite effort
to improve skill sets and narrow gaps
yes i do do i think that the life we're
currently all living is the most
challenging we've seen for some time
absolutely so it will make it more
difficult but if we do not do these
things and i i really mean addressing
education in the first place as well as
training and skills thereafter unless we
do not do those things with belief and
commitment you know simply we will not
be internationally competitive and
ultimately that is what counts so you
know for me what good looks like is
seeing evidence of that in a continuing
government policy
and encouragement of business to truly
interact with government to develop a
plan as to what good can look like and
that relationship of government and
industry
is fundamental to the success of any of
these plans neither can do it in
isolation together we can be very
effective
isabel i wonder if you detect certain
tension in government policy here alex
burkhart is telling us how he'd be quite
happy if there were fewer undergraduates
fewer people going to university i
remember not so long ago when joe
johnson was the university's minister of
course he's now in the house of lords
but joe johnson's manifesto was exactly
the opposite you wanted far more people
going to university to grow the
university sector
and so i can't work out when if we're
witnessing a change in tory thinking or
simply two contradictory policies
operating in
the same government
yeah i think it's probably the latter
unfortunately that there's a lot of
confusion and
diversity within government on what
targets should be which is uh is not
great in terms of working out whether
they're going to be successful or not
and another example of that is is
working from home i mean
you talk to most people involved in in
leveling up projects they will say that
working from home is is an important
part of that because it means that you
don't have to have place-based
recruiting um whereas we've had a lot of
noise uh over the past few weeks and i
know that's partly uh in relation to the
civil service about um ministers jacob
reese morgan particularly being very
down on on working from home now i mean
does the government support that or not
whether it's to do with the civil
service in in the regions or or actually
business more more widely
okay well that's and brings us to the
end of our session isabelle so roger and
alex berger thank you very much for for
joining me here
and now delighted to introduce the man
we were speaking about earlier neil
o'brien the minister in the leveling up
department um who's going to close our
session today with some thoughts neil
o'brien over to you
well thank you fraser i am it's been a
super interesting discussion and it
shows you the breadth of the kind of
leveling up agenda
um so i think there are a couple of a
couple of takeaways uh that i have from
it and a couple of thoughts that i would
try and leave you with
so i think uh
your discussion this morning has been
useful because so often
discussion about leveling up goes to a
couple of things very quickly either
goes to kind of discussion about big
infrastructure projects which are of
course really really important uh you
know the 96 billion pounds we're
spending on the
integrated rail plan
you know it's something that you can see
all over the country happening if you
come here up to the midlands you would
see
uh all the new electrification uh you
know snaking its way up between london
and sheffield and it's a huge project
these things are very important you know
the five billion pounds we're spending
on project gig a bit tangible thing that
lots of people across the country are
getting letters saying they can now get
fiber broadband you know these are big
things but they're not all of what
leveling up is about you know
it is about i think a couple of
different things that are genuinely new
because we are very conscious of the
record of many governments trying these
things before and not succeeding
and i think
a couple of the ways that we're doing
things differently are firstly to really
try and empower local leaders it the uk
is an unusual country in so far as
um the role of local leadership has been
so weak relatively actually boris is a
bit of an exception in so far as he's
come from being a senior person in local
government to be prime minister which is
a totally normal thing to do in america
and most other countries but in britain
is pretty unusual and that has meant
that we don't have those powerful local
voices happening in their areas we don't
have those powerful local actors
bringing together all the different
things that inward investors
need nobody to join up you know the
skills plan the infrastructure plan and
the tax needs of a place the inward
investors other needs so we are starting
to change that in different ways through
our devolution deals
taking the model that we've now
got well established in our bigger
cities and bringing it to
a lot of the rest of uh england and
because of course in 2010 we started
with a situation with
where only london had uh devolved powers
which is good for london it was great
for london to have an inward investment
agency great for london to have a
charismatic uh mayor going and selling
the city around the world the problem
was that the rest of the country didn't
have those things now we are
changing that
but it's not just those big shiny
devolution deals that uh we mean when we
talk about empowering local leaders it's
also about giving every place the
financial firepower to do the things it
needs to level up and we've talked
already about
um the leveling up fund 4.8 billion
pounds the towns fund which brings
together you mentioned phrases in the
last session about grimsby and the way
that lots of different businesses the
local councils and other people with the
stake have come together there to drive
the town forward we're doing that
through the fund in lots of other places
and now through the shared prosperity
fund that launched just the other week
we're giving people really flexible
funding um with a lot of local control
over it that replaces the european money
which used to come with a lot of
bureaucracy and strings attached now
that will be in the hands of locally
elected leaders not remote regional
bureaucracies so they can really drive
the projects that are important uh to
them
and as well as the financial firefighter
we're giving places the support they
need to do things that they are trying
to do at the moment every town and city
center in the country every high street
needs to change fundamentally because
we're all shopping online uh partly the
effects of the pandemic and every town
and city centre needs to regenerate
perhaps become a place to to live and
work not just to go shopping and so how
do we give people the tools that they
need to bring off these huge once in a
generation maybe even once in a couple
of centuries changes to their towns and
cities that's why we have got homes
england back into the business of
helping places to do major regeneration
projects of the kind that mrs thatcher
and michael hesseltein did in the
docklands in the 1980s
um and of course we are also empowering
businesses not just about local
politicians through things like local
skills uh plans the kind of things that
alex was just talking about we're
bringing
business into shaping the way we spend
our skills budget so instead of being
what a bureaucrat guesses local
community and local businesses need it's
what local businesses themselves um tell
us that they need so at all levels we
are empowering local leaders of
different kinds to drive forward their
local communities not just something
that is being run out of whitehall
and i think the second way that we are
doing things differently uh this time is
to focus not just on having a little a
specific budget that's uh for you know
leveling up many many previous
governments have had pots of money for
regional policy and things like that
what we're doing is trying to
fundamentally reshape um the whole way
that we uh approach things the whole way
that we spend um taxpayers money and the
hell dane's already uh touched on this
but instead of just thinking about those
funds that i mentioned funds for
leveling up explicitly we're thinking
about how we can reshape those bigger
government budgets that haven't been
thought of spatially before how do we
take our r d budget for example our
innovation budget which is growing
pretty dramatically in the next couple
of years and use it to drive innovation
as well as just academic research how do
we make sure that it's driving
innovation outside the golden triangle
of oxford cambridge in london and that's
why we've set a target for the first
time ever to grow spending outside the
greater southeast by a third of the next
three years group
taxpayer investment into those places by
third over three years very dramatic
change the way we uh spend money but the
same is happening in other budgets too
the way we've
changed the balance of housing
and regeneration spending to help get
more activity going in places that have
been
left behind for many years so getting
rid of uh things like the 80 20 rule
which overrode the value for money
considerations um changing the way the
treasury's green book rules work so that
we have uh recognition of the potential
of places to grow not just their current
uh rates of growth and demand and the
underlying all that is a sense that we
have that there is a kind of win-win
here there's opportunity
from the leveling up agenda to have a
stronger economy
overall it is a private sector focused
agenda because we know that
without growing the private sector it
will fundamentally fail you won't
strengthen the places that we are trying
to strengthen for the long term
but there is an opportunity to make the
economy overall we think stronger
because if you have an economy as we've
had for many years where you have parts
of
the country overheating where you can't
get on the train in the morning because
it's so congested where the house prices
are already sky high
and yet at the same time you have other
parts of the country that are crying out
for investment and have space they have
underused assets they have a slack and
labor market then you can see that there
is the potential for a win-win i think
it's no accident that countries that are
more overall balanced economies in the
uk have performed more stronger have
higher living standards higher incomes
and higher gdp so that is what we are
fundamentally in the business of uh of
doing i think it's an incredibly
exciting agenda this morning's
conference has uh talked about some of
the ways that people can get involved in
that agenda and so i think it's been a
really valuable contribution and thank
you for for hosting it i hope it's given
people a bit of a strength of the sense
of the breadth of the agenda here
is not just an economic agenda although
it's centrally an economic agenda it's
also bringing in all those questions
about poor health which can
dog an area's economy as well as
reducing its living standards
bringing in those considerations about
quality of life and the way that places
feel and the opportunities that people
have not just how their economy is
performing so it is an exciting agenda
it's an agenda that is is broad
and i hope that people who have been
involved in your conference this morning
will think about how they can get
involved in it how they can be part of
it through their businesses too and how
we can work together with you to try and
make a big difference for this country
and achieve the potential of a lot of
places that have so much more to give
thank you so much fraser
neil o'brien thanks very much indeed and
that brings us to the end of today's
conference um i hope you've enjoyed
watching thank you for your questions i
hope we went some way to
answering them if you've got any more
than do email us and info spectator dot
co dot uk
we'd like to thank bae systems for
making today possible and i'd also like
to thank cindy you and her production
team for putting this show together stay
tuned to spectator tv's youtube channel
for with a week in 60 minutes and other
shows as we do our best to make sense
with politics as it happens